en el vídeo pasado estábamos hablando
acerca de la curva de demanda y nos
topamos que también era una curva de
beneficio marginal una curva de
beneficio marginal y es que nos dábamos
cuenta que para cada unidad de
automóviles que nosotros vendiéramos
cada punto que estuviera sobre la curva
de la demanda implicaba que esa era su
beneficio marginal por lo tanto para dos
automóviles este era nuestro beneficio
marginal para tres automóviles ese era
nuestro beneficio marginal y así
sucesivamente para la unidad siguiente y
es que todo esto está pensado para el
incremento en la unidad por ejemplo si
nosotros nos fijamos cuando vendemos un
automóvil nosotros vamos a vender ese
automóvil en 60 mil pesos mientras que
si nosotros vendíamos dos automóviles
entonces sí vamos a vender cada uno de
sus automóviles en 50 mil pesos existía
una persona que era todo lo que podía
pagar y pasó lo mismo cuando son tres
automóviles existe otra persona que
solamente puede poner 40 mil pesos y no
más pues ya están sus gastos al límite
otra persona en el caso de 4 otra
persona que no es ninguna de las otras
tres que dice que por 30 mil pesos si se
compra ese automóvil así que decidamos
al azar que este es el precio que
establecemos y es de 30 mil pesos y
entonces decimos que en la forma
tradicional de comparar la noción de
precio y cantidad ya hablamos de la
cantidad que estamos vendiendo entonces
tenemos esta cuarta persona que está en
el límite en su beneficio marginal es
exactamente 30 mil pesos en sus mentes
así que nos dice que le estoy regalando
30 mil pesos en el intercambio de este
auto nuevo cuyo valor es exactamente 30
mil pesos es como si nos dijera a hey
quieres hablar en términos de peso por
peso y bueno te cuento todo esto porque
seguramente tarde o temprano una cuarta
persona estará cerca del límite y estará
muy cerca de dejar ir esta oportunidad y
secuestrar un poco menos en su dado caso
la compraría sin pensarlo pero como
estamos cerca del límite entonces no
puede comprar este automóvil en ese
momento es cuando esa cuarta persona se
da cuenta de que ella es la cuarta
persona y que hace que el precio sea de
esta manera y bueno como estamos
hablando de un precio para todos y en un
futuro no voy a hablar de este precio
para todos es importante ver que todas
estas unidades se pudieran vender a un
precio más bajo
al cual se estaban vendiendo se pudieron
vender abajo de su beneficio marginal y
bueno recuerda que hablar de la misma
curva de demanda no es hablar de la
misma curva de beneficio marginal cuando
son los mismos precios así que veamos
esta primera unidad este primer
automóvil que se podría vender a 60 mil
pesos ahora se está vendiendo a 30 mil
pesos en este precio que tenemos de 30
mil pesos estaba a 30 mil pesos arriba
del precio con el que estamos trabajando
entonces el beneficio marginal de esta
primera unidad cuando sólo teníamos una
unidad es de 30 mil pesos mayor al
precio actual ahora en el caso de la
segunda unidad es 20 mil pesos mayor al
precio total en el precio en el cual se
está vendiendo este producto y en el
caso de esta tercera unidad ese tercer
automóvil tenemos un beneficio marginal
de 10 mil pesos suponiendo si estamos en
40 mil pesos aquí otra forma de verlo es
que el excedente al consumidor para esta
primera unidad era de 30 mil pesos o
justo hablando del excedente al
consumidor que en esta primera unidad es
30 mil pesos arriba en el beneficio
marginal
ellos del valor que nosotros tenemos que
pagar y en la segunda unidad el
excedente del consumidor es 20 mil pesos
el excedente del consumidor es de 20 mil
pesos más que el valor que está justo
por pagar en este mismo momento y en el
caso del tercer consumidor tiene un
excedente del consumidor de 10 mil pesos
mientras que el cuarto consumidor es
neutral su beneficio marginal es justo
lo que va a pagar por el automóvil y
bueno ahora la pregunta va a ser cuál es
el total del excedente del consumidor
aquí buscamos el total del excedente del
consumidor y no es más menos que sumar
todos los excedentes del consumidor de
cada uno de los tres este automóviles y
digo de estos tres automóviles porque
acabamos de ver que el cuarto es neutral
es decir que no tiene un excedente del
consumidor entonces habrá que sumar 30
más 20 más la cantidad del excedente del
consumidor del tercer auto que es 10.000
y bueno todo esto están dado en miles de
pesos y 30 más 2010 la cantidad que me
va a dar son 60 mil pesos y ojo tampoco
hay que olvidar que no podemos vender
partecitas de auto es decir no estamos
vendiendo los autos por partes no
estamos vendiendo 1 punto auto 2.3 autos
etcétera y bueno ahora sí si hacemos
esta suma quedamos que eran 60 mil pesos
el total del excedente del consumidor
son 60 mil pesos y ya para finalizar
este vídeo quiero que te des cuenta de
lo siguiente los consumidores están
ahorrando 60 mil pesos a diferencia de
comprar los autos en otra cantidad de
consumidores y también ten en cuenta que
de igual manera para el vendedor el
vendedor está dejando de ganar dinero
que podría ganar si los vendiera por
separado sin embargo está ganando que
con estos cuatro consumidores se venda
todo su producto de una misma vez
entonces por aquí vamos a dejar este
vídeo y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo